>> Time is the great equalizer
in hospitals all across Turkey.
There is not enough of it here
in adana at the teaching and
research hospital.
>> The patients come in with
fractures, what sort of
injuries?
The patients consist of tissue
lost, brain trauma.
>> This doctor's chief of staff
here.
Within minutes, his trauma team
is paged again.
Another helicopter is arriving.
We are now walking with the
chief of staff of the hospital
to the helipad.
He tells me they've had some
5000 patients who have come
here over the last several days.
The orthopedic surgeons, the
neuro surgeons have been
operating for seven days
straight, basically.
This is the largest trauma
hospital in the quake zone.
>> The doctors move fast.
The goal is to care for this
26-year-old woman.
Her kidneys are failing from
something a known as crush
syndrome.
She will need kidney dialysis.
Patients from the quake zone
finally, thankfully making it
here for help.
With the most remarkable story
I have heard, this beautiful
family of five felt the Earth
shake and then watched the
unthinkable happened.
>> Translator: The block of
flatter seven stories high.
>> They could do nothing but
watch as an eight month old
baby was somehow hurdled from
the window, five stories to the
ground.
Look what happened to their
building, just flattened.
Somehow, she survived after
being trapped herself for
almost 14 hours.
She began to dig and scrape
through the rubble for any sign,
any sign at all that her baby
girl was still alive.
>> Translator: At that point,
the fifth day, we thought we
would be seeing her lifeless
body.
>> Something astonishing up
and.
Someone showed them this post
on Twitter.
At first, they were not sure,
but this baby girl looked very
much like her daughter.
>> Translator: You see, we had
no idea she had been saved.
>> In the chaos, a good
samaritan had rescued the girl
and she was flown here, broken